[Music]
Pikul reg Gary for all you know this is
the equivalent of an alien truck stop
you have no frame of reference you're in
a universe beyond your imagining but yes
it is super fancy nope regular blood
[Music]
[Applause]
new Rick and Morty everybody let's break
it down and I added the title sequence
to this too because we finally got the
new one there's a bunch of new scenes so
it's pretty easy to tell which ones are
fake and which ones are new so I'll
start with that but there is a new round
of the merch giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video I announce winners
at the end of videos so here we go
starting with the title sequence it's
basically an alternating pattern of fake
real fake real fake so there's five
scenes starting with season two they
were a little more consistent I'll play
a little bit of the intros from season
one and season two so you can compare
just chopping off the bits that are the
same the first scene with the math
problem in the eyeball floating by in
space and the last scene of the monster
chasing them into the title is the exact
same in every single case
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
so you can see that in season one there
were a lot more fake scenes it wasn't
till season two till they started
alternating the fake real fake real fake
but interestingly enough they still
include five separate scenes whether or
not they're fake or real love the first
one of Beth catching Morty looking at
naked women on the Internet
only their butts have been swapped with
their faces surprise surprise everybody
has butt faces so we'll just call this
the butt based reality I don't even want
to think about the logistics of that
then there's the real scene with summer
in Terminator summer inside the Galactic
government looking like they're trying
to help Rick out then by the logic of
alternating fake scenes with real scenes
this must be fake with all the Morty's
trying to help each other escape little
lizard Morty creeping out the side even
if this piano scene isn't from Episode
two we know that it's real because we've
seen it in the season 3 trailer in all
of that confirmed footage from the
season in this last one is probably one
of my favorite ones I mean the butt face
one is pretty awesome but I love the
idea that Rick goes to the Morty store
shopping for new Morty's based on the
accessory weapons that come with them it
is he settles one and walks away without
putting the other one back you see that
they're all alive and there is his face
gets all wide as it gets ready to smash
it on the ground let me know in the
comments though what's your favorite
part of the new intro but faces or the
Morty's store most of the stuff they've
been dropping is in service of hyping up
Sunday's episode with the exception of
the non-canonical adventures but we
talked a bunch about the pickle Rick
scene where he basically tries to cheer
Morty up because they're all bummed out
because Jerry's gone and he gets himself
into a literal and metaphorical pickle
as he becomes a pickle that falls down
into the sewer and has to prevent
himself from being eaten alive by rats
that was the animatic that they released
a Comic Con last year
[Applause]
[Music]
so what'll happen is they'll probably
continue posting clips through the
weekend I don't know if they'll be
posting this many clips after every
single episode but whatever ends up
happening I'll totally do a video for it
so leave all your bonus video requests
in the comments below I know a lot of
you been asking for the comic-con panel
so here's a little bit more of that I'll
post the rest of it on Saturday morning
there's nothing more therapeutic than
spending way too long on a season and
then looking back on it and going that's
only 5 percent more genius than the past
two seasons so we're going to work on
we're like I can do it now I can write
really fast that's the cold open to
remember and the rest of it we've had
enough of plot here
they're absolutely padded by Justin
riffing about a long discontinued
Szechuan sauce or some product see that
guy right there we got one of the pros
really guys guys I have to tell you you
waited in line for so long for this
panel and I'm going to give you a crazy
like exclusive little nugget of
information I am officially going to be
getting a biggest liter bottle of the
original recipe Szechuan thoughts
from McDonald's delivered to the Rick
and Morty offices and we are definitely
going to film the taste we're all gonna
taste it we're all going how riot come
enjoy the real thing this is actually
going to happen it's happening I think
it's coming next week or something it
would have happened if you didn't wait
in line but what I'm telling you here I
saved it for this moment what was it
different how old were like yeah cool
good for you we want to try it where we
teeing up like a bit like where it was
like oh just another show this season is
going to be awesome just a reminder that
it's supposed to be episode two just
based on the TV Guide so I'm just
assuming that that is correct so what
will happen is is I'll post my video on
Monday morning after it airs just
because so much Game of Thrones stuff
will be happening earlier in the evening
congratulations to Renee's Nisbet you're
the latest Rick and Morty merch giveaway
winner it's just from their Zen monkey
studios please private message be on the
back end of my channel so I can get your
contact details while you wait for
everything you can click here for more
Rick and Morty season 3 episode 2 and
you can click here for the trailer for
next week's game of Thrones thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
[Applause]